well it is time to lace up those bowling  shoes and knock some fans over the bull  for gold fundraiser for the special  olympics of nevada is back the event  took place earlier today at the strike  zone bowling center that's at sunset  station and hey you recognize this guy  our very own john langler hosted the  event donations raised with help will  help rather somv with its efforts to  establish an independently run chapter  here in nevada  so right now special olympics nevada is  under special olympics northern  california and our goal is to be our own  chapter special olympics nevada run by  special olympics nevada by the end of  2023 we are so excited and we really  want it to happen so we can really  support our athletes in a real  consistent way  the fundraiser also helps support a  number of programs for people with  intellectual disabilities